[Music]
welcome everyone
to the ai illusion a debate that we're
going to
have about artificial intelligence now a
third of all companies worldwide claim
to have implemented
ai in some form and more than two-thirds
in the united kingdom and the united
states
the critics argue that this is just
marketing hype
artificial intelligence has not yet
happened and there's no sign of it being
anywhere near about to happen luke julia
who's samsung's vice president of
innovation
has stated that we have better machines
than in the past
but they don't involve artificial forms
of intelligence
should we see the future of automation
and machine learning
and give up on more super intelligence
forms of ai
might this make us feel less scared and
more in control of the future
or is artificial intelligence's
revolution not only on its way
but already here and changing our world
radically
but better or for worse with me to
discuss this today
and with you are four incredible
speakers
so i'm going to quickly introduce them
and give a brief biography and then we
will dive right in
so first up martin reese martin has
co-authored more than 500
academic papers on subjects as
intoxicating as the big bang
and dark matter he's currently
astronomer royal
is a long-standing member of the house
of lords and has previously
been president of the royal society a
position that isaac
newton once held more recently martin
authored on the future prospects for
humanity
in which he discussed the dangers that
humanity will face in the next century
including the potential risks of ai
our next speaker is laura mercini
houghton
she's a cosmologist theoretical
physicist and professor at the
university of north carolina we're very
happy to have her joining us across the
atlantic
her work focuses on the birth of our
universe
she's a proponent of the multiverse
theory which suggests that we are
just one of many universes her theories
have been successfully backed up
by much after she appeared on the bbc
program
what happened before the big bang um
and is going to definitely have some
really fascinating debates i suspect
with martin
on some of these points our third
speaker is hilary
lawson he is a postmodern philosopher
and a renowned critic of philosophical
realism
he's the author of reflexivity the
post-modern predicament
which argues that the paradoxes of
self-reference
have been central to 20th century
philosophy he is perhaps best known for
his
theory of closure which puts forward
non-realist metaphysics
and contends that we close the openness
of the world
with our thought and language last but
not least
is kate dublin she is a computer
scientist
sex robot theorist senior lecturer in
social and cultural artificial
intelligence at
king's college london and the author of
turned on
science sex and robots she has
previously said that instead of fearing
the rise of machines
we could quite literally embrace them
so introduction's over we're going to
dive in
each speaker is going to address a
question and give three minutes
to that question and then we'll proceed
on the debate
so first just three minutes times four
speakers is 12.
the question that we'll go for first is
should we give up talk of artificial
intelligence in terms of
super intelligence for instance and
focus on more limited
applications such as automation and
machine learning
so martin reese your thoughts in three
minutes
please yes well i think we should avoid
semantics
and just ask what machines will do and
what they're unlikely ever to do
the main point is that they work a
million times or more faster than us
so they can absorb data and process data
much quicker
and that's why they can do amazing
things they do amazing calculations
they can uh monitor and control
elaborate networks um and they're very
useful for that
um and they can um learn as we
know to play games like s and go
and do better than human beings but
essentially because they can play
against themselves one game per second
and so they gain experience very very
fast
and of course um what we worry about
is if decisions about us are made by a
machine
then do we trust it even if it's
normally right
are you prepared to uh accept its
judgments uh if
it's going to decide whether we uh uh
get released in prison
have an operation or get credit
something like that that's a big issue
but
i think we must be excited about the
prospects of
um advanced artificial intelligence um
certainly it can help
a quants stock broker to do better than
any human player
if the chinese wanted to have a
completely planned economy
they could have it in a way that mark
could never dream of by being able to uh
gather all the data and process it and
uh
in science um i think it will
enable us to make discoveries because it
can already do many things better than
humans
can human mathematicians you can analyze
data much much faster
find weak correlations we would miss and
uh to touch base a bit with lara
i think if the uh basic physics of the
big bang
involves string theory in 10 or 11
dimensions the mathematics may be too
hard for any human
but ai may do the calculations and spew
out the
other and if that answer accords with
observation
then we have to take the theory
seriously so there's huge potential
but of course the science fiction
idea is that these machines will
interact with the uh the real world
and here it's much more difficult
because they can only interact with the
external world
via something like the internet of
things um and we know that robots are
very clumsy
compared to real people and so when
people talk about the kind of jobs that
are going to be taken over
by uh machines um it's more likely to be
certain
um white collar jobs um accountancy and
things like that
i don't imagine ever that a machine is
going to be able to be a plumber
because if you think what that involves
it involves going to a strange house
poking around to find a leak and using
tools to mend it
that's the kind of job and gardening is
similar where machines will
never realistically take over but they
will take over
and uh as if they're complementary to
what they're doing this is definitely a
class
so i don't think we worry about the
singularity as i say
we have to worry about um what
these can do and how we can ensure that
the people whose
jobs are displaced are given more
interesting jobs
instead so just to make one point in
those ones the jobs to be easily
displaced
are the mind-numbing jobs like being uh
in an amazon warehouse or a call center
great if they can be replaced provided
that the companies
own them can be taxed and the money used
to fund lots of jobs for carers
and things like that where the human
life is crucial so they're not going to
take over
humans but they can complement and
amplify what humans can do
so i welcome these developments we've
got to keep our eye on them
yes so well as the philosopher on the
panel perhaps i'd like to begin with
just
saying something about the broader sort
of conceptual framework
which might help us understand how we
different people take up different
relationships in relation to
artificial intelligence so in general
and these are very broad brush things
people who are materialist that is
people who think that the world is made
of physical
stuff and there is only that physical
stuff
tend to think that um it's going to be
possible to build
an artificially intelligent machine um
because after a machine is is made of
physical bits and in
principle there's no reason why one
couldn't do it
but there are a whole lot of people who
don't accept that the world is just
material
and who think that there are other
things that things like thought
and consciousness are different sort of
stuff and therefore
they tend to think that it's not
possible for artificially intelligent
machines
to be uh to be possible um
now having laid out that basic sort of
framework i'm going to confuse you
because
i'm a i'm not a materialist i don't
think the world just consists of
material
um and i'm also not a realist in the
sense that i don't think that
our thoughts and language describe the
world
but i do think that it is possible to
make
uh or will be possible to make uh
intelligent
machines i don't think we're remotely
close at the moment
i think there's a vast amount of hype
about uh artificial intelligence every
other company is saying they're using
artificial intelligence they're not at
all
it's just a form of machine
products as it were that's there's no
intelligence going on there
but i think that in principle it could
be possible and very
briefly the reason i think that's the
case is because
the way i think humans work is that they
don't
understand the world by seeing how it
really is
they understand the world by making
uh by taking as it were their input data
and holding it in certain ways
in order to be able to intervene so let
me give you an example of
from vision so in the case of a vision
the neurons in the eye i'll adopt the
scientific model for a moment there are
other models but uh
the neurons in the eye either fire or
they don't in response to a stimulus
their firing is not a description of the
world it's a response to the world it
either fires or it doesn't fire
and that that choice of it firing or not
firing
is its way to the way that neuron as it
were responds to the world
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas